how do you make a good first impression
with a potential investor or sponsor for
your business that's a question that
came in from one of our YouTube viewers
muzika who wrote in to say that I had
secured a meeting with a potential
sponsor for the business and wanted my
advice and what to say and what to do so
first of all Congrats that's a big jump
Congrats on reaching out and getting
somebody to say yes and agree to a
meeting huge step forward and hopefully
will help propel your business to the
next step in terms of what to say when
you get to that meeting a few tips that
will help you out number one understand
what they want so if they're sponsoring
your business I don't know what it is
that you do but if they're sponsoring
you they're after a certain outcome so
what is it
but if if it's some kind of charitable
event maybe they want exposure in the
community maybe they want some online
exposure maybe they want lots of people
to visit their website whatever it is
understanding what their goals are
there's probably a number of ways you
can help them out but you want to know
what their objectives are to start a lot
of entrepreneurs get that wrong a lot of
salespeople get that wrong they just
started to their pitch where the person
who's receiving it they're only seeing
one or two things not everything so you
want to try to target your message and
it comes from listening and
understanding what they're after
so start by asking questions get a
handle of why they're interested in you
then you could tailor your presentation
number two to show them a desired
outcome so now you know they want show
them how you can help them get it right
so if it's increasing visits to their
site increasing sales for them getting
more people following them on Twitter
whatever it is that their goal is you
want to show how you are going to be
able to help them if they sponsor you
the more tangible you can make it the
easier it's going to get them to say yes
and number three is tell stories stories
add a personal element to it it's great
to have facts and figures and to solve a
need but when you can add a story
whether it's your own personal story or
the story of another client who's gone
through it or some of that your help
as a result of them sponsoring your
event then that's gonna add a more
personal element to it and increase the
chances of them saying yes
so good luck listen to them understand
what it is that they're really looking
for target your presentation towards
them and show them the outcome and then
tell the story around it I know it's
really hard I remember when I was first
pitching my first angel ambassador for
my business I was scared
this guy had just sold his business for
700 million dollars and I wanted to get
a little bit of that to help fund my
business
and remember meeting him at a coffee
shop with my business partner and and
sweating bullets hoping that the
presentation would go WOW and we had
spent weeks preparing for this and we
got frustrated no we're sitting on the
couch day after day after day practicing
and wishing that we could have him for a
whole afternoon to walk him through
everything but you don't have that
luxury
now you've got to make an impact right
away you may have a maximum 20 minutes
with these guys and so you got to really
make that impact and let them know that
hey this is something they want to do
business with so practice your pitch
refine it down talk to yourself in the
mirror go over it again and again and
again the more practice you have the
better it's gonna be talk to your cat
talk to your dog practice in front of
somebody else so you get that feedback
as well and you get used to it even if
you're just presenting and your dogs in
front of you just getting used to having
somebody watch you even though it's not
another human being
helps prepare you so you're not as
nervous when you go into your
presentation so good luck keep us posted
I want to hear how how it went and if
you have any other questions let me know
those are you watching if you like the
video please give it a thumbs up below
what makes you want to do more videos
for you and if you have a question about
this video or question for your own
business I'd love to try to help if you
want leave it in the comments below I
always read those so thank you and I'll
see you on the next episode